can a man approach his wife during the
month of Ramadan in the evening after
the fasted ended
previously when fasting became
f for the Muslims as Allah says in the
Quran in Surah bakap 2 verse number 185
that Ramadan is the month in which the
Quran was revealed as a guide for
humankind and giving you signs of
guidance and judgment between right and
wrong and then it says that so whoever
Witnesses this month he should fast so
when it became f for the Muslim the
first time initially the full month of
Ramadan at that time it was the law that
approaching your wives having a sexual
intercourse with your wife for the full
month of Ramadan whether it be day or
night was
prohibited and it's mentioned in the of
Al M number two page number
210 that Omar may Allah be pleased with
him once he spends a lot of De of time
with the prophet and leaves the prophet
at night and comes to his house and when
he reaches the house he has the urge to
sleep with his wife and he has
intercourse when he gets up in the
morning he's ashamed and he goes to the
prophet and says that I sinned against
Allah and you so the prophet say why
because I slept with my wife my soul
urged and went towards my wife and I
slept with her and had intercourse with
her Prophet said did you really do
that said yes andar says that can you
find a pardon for me and then Prophet
says no one besides Allah can pardon you
he's the only one who can show you the
way and immediately the ver of the Quran
of Surah Bak chapter number two verse
number 187 was revealed it says that you
can approach your wife during the nights
of the
fast because they are your garments and
you are their garments and then the ver
continues that and Allah knows what you
to do secretly in the nights with your
wives but Allah has forgiven you and
from now onwards you can approach your
wives and you can take what Allah gives
you the offing from then and you can eat
and drink till the white thread of dawn
is distinct from the black
thread and then you can fast until
sunset until night falls so when this
verse was revealed Sur Bak CH 2 verse
number 187 then it became lawful for the
Muslims to approach their wife during
the nights of the fast so now as far the
present rule is that you cannot approach
your wives have a sexual intercourse
with them during the day right from the
break of dawn from the time of f Salah
up to sun
but immediately after Sunset up to just
before the break of dawn Salah you can
approach your wife and lawful and you
can have relationship with them